tema de green para resolver algunos
problemas de integrales de líneas pero
antes de meternos con eso quiero hacer
una precisión con respecto al teorema de
grimm en todos los ejemplos que hice
tener una región así y lo que quiero que
observes es que la región siempre
quedaba a la izquierda de la trayectoria
cuando la recorrimos en sentido
antihorario porque pues siempre que
recurrimos en sentido antihorario algo
por ejemplo puedes imaginarte una pista
para correr el centro de la región
siempre nos va a quedar a la izquierda
bueno justo necesitamos esta situación
para aplicar el teorema de greene así si
tomamos una integral de línea digamos un
integral de líneas sobre esta
trayectoria a veces esta es la anotación
para poner el sentido antihorario bueno
si tomamos esta trayectoria de f punto
de r esto de aquí es lo que es igual a
la integral doble en la región r
de qué cosa de la parcial de q con
respecto a x menos la parcial de p con
respecto ayer y aquí le ponemos de a
nada más para acordarnos estas pq vienen
de las componentes del campo vectorial f
efe es algo del estilo fx y es igual a p
de xy x el vector y más q de x jay x el
vector j va entonces esta es la
situación en la cual el interior de la
región queda a la izquierda de la
dirección de la trayectoria podremos
arreglarlo para cuando queda a la
derecha si simplemente hay que poner un
menos aquí porque pues bueno si la
flecha va para el sentido contrario
entonces estamos recorriendo la
trayectoria en dirección opuesta y por
tanto su integral de línea simplemente
cambia de signo entonces en realidad no
es un gran problema simplemente hay que
estar muy atentos a eso vale bueno
aprovechando que ya tenemos el teorema
de greene aquí escrito vamos a pasar
ahora sí a un ejemplo supongamos que nos
piden la integral de línea de la
trayectoria se ahorita te digo quienes
se de la siguiente expresión
x cuadrada
menos cuadrada
de equis
[Música]
2x si de ella nuestra curva la vamos a
definir como la frontera de una región a
ver lo voy a escribir por acá voy a
ponerle la hipótesis de este estilo le
voy a poner a ver dice la curva es la
frontera
de la región r y ahorita te digo cómo
está dada la región r está dada por los
puntos xy tales que cumplan lo siguiente
que 0 es menor o igual que x que es
menor o igual a 1 y si es mayor o igual
que 2x cuadrada y es menor o igual que
2x vamos a hacer un dibujo para que nos
quede muy claro esto a ver voy a poner
por acá los ejes este de aquí un poco
más para campo con más derechito este de
aquí es el eje y luego voy a dibujar
aquí abajo perpendicularmente el eje x
y entonces x se mueve de 0 a 1 a ver voy
a marcar aquí 0 aquí voy a marcar el 1
entonces voy a poner esta línea vertical
y en donde se mueve bueno se mueve entre
2 x cuadrada y 2 x usualmente x cuadrado
más grande que x pero en el intervalo 0
1 x cuadrado es más pequeño que x
entonces el límite superior va a ser 2 x
a ver si por aquí está el 2 tenemos la
línea ya igual a 2 x por aquí voy a
ponerle un poco más derechista sube sube
sube y toca aquí el punto 1 2 y donde
queda la otra curva a ver la otra es 2 x
cuadrada
esta que la voy a pintar con rosa
mexicano pasa por abajo de la recta que
es igual a igual a 2x cuadrada y las
regiones esta de aquí esta que estoy
sombreando estas hipótesis que tenemos
ah me falta una hipótesis hay que poner
que va en sentido antihorario va esto va
a ser para que podamos usar el teorema
de green directamente entonces vamos a
recorrer la curva en este sentido de
aquí nos vamos para acá de regreso
y entonces como te decía esta hipótesis
es para que podamos usar el teorema de
green directamente pues el interior ya
nos queda a la izquierda es decir no
tenemos que pensar en signos menos
mirada del estilo ahora sí pasemos a la
integral doble la integral doble que nos
da el teorema de greene va a ser la
integral y aquí hay que poner donde se
mueve y entonces en donde se mueve pues
a ver aquí más derechito y igual a 2x
cuadrada es el límite inferior y el
límites superiores ye igual a 2x
van
ok entonces estamos integrando con
respecto a ayer y luego tenemos que
poner la integral de afuera la integral
de x nos queda la integral los límites
están más fáciles es 0 1 y aquí le pongo
d
que va aquí adentro pues lo que va aquí
adentro es lo que nos dice el teorema de
green ciertas parciales entonces esta
expresión ésta es la f va entonces
tenemos fx y es igual a que consta pues
a x cuadrada menos cuadrada por y más 2x
y por jota ya lo habíamos visto en otros
vídeos verdad cuando tomamos el producto
punto con de r justo obtenemos el
integrando de acá entonces esté
integrando es nuestro p de xy y el otro
sumando este sumando de acá es el q de
xy
listo ya con todo planteado ya podemos
pasar a las cuentitas está bueno
hacerlas para que ahora sí nos quede un
número entonces la parcial de q con
respecto a x es lo primero que tenemos
que hacer la parcial de 12 15 con
respecto a x es simplemente 2
y ahora de ahí tenemos que restar la
parcial de p este de aquí es p con
respecto a y la parcial de x cuadrado
con respecto al cero y luego hay que
restar la derivada de ye cuadrada con
respecto a y entonces nos queda menos 2
entonces lo pongo por aquí nos queda
menos 2
ahora vamos a simplificar esta expresión
de aquí tenemos dos menos menos dos
entonces nos queda dos más dos estamos
restando un negativo entonces nos queda
positivo vamos a ahorrar un poco de
espacio déjame borrar esta expresión de
aquí para poner el 4 i
ok y entonces aquí podemos poner 4 y
otra vez nos vamos aquí arriba la
parcial de aquí esto luego hay que
restar la parcial de x cuadrado menos de
cuadrada que es menos 2 entonces dos
gemelos menos dos llenos queda cuatro y
va ya tenemos que hacer la integral aquí
directamente cuál es la anti derivada de
cuatro ya cuadrada pues es 2 ya cuadrada
vamos a hacerlo aquí abajo para tener un
poco más de espacio nos queda 2 y
cuadrada
ok si derivamos 2 de cuadradas nos queda
y esto lo tenemos que evaluar de
pues a ver aquí abajo le tengo que poner
2 x cuadrada y aquí arriba ya iguala 2x
y por supuesto todavía queda la integral
de afuera la integral de 0 a 1 de esta
expresión de x muy bien aquí nos queda
igual a la integral de 0 a 1 aquí
tenemos que evaluar en ambos valores de
y si ponemos ya igual a 2 x nos queda
haber 2 x al cuadrado en es 4x cuadrada
y luego tenemos que multiplicar por otro
2 entonces 34 x cuadrada x 28 x cuadrada
y luego tenemos que restar este aquí
entonces 2 x cuadrada elevado al
cuadrado es 4 x a la cuarta más 4x a la
cuarta x 2 es 8 x a la cuarta menos 8 x
a la cuarta no no no me equivocado
verdad 2 x al cuadrado al cuadrado 4 x a
la cuarta x 2 nos queda 8 x a la cuarta
todo va muy bien y ahora esto de aquí
tenemos que ponerle un de equis y nos
queda una integral de las bien bien
sencillas de las de cálculo 1 verdad
entonces esto de aquí es igual a la anti
derivada de 8x cuadradas 8 tercios de x
al cubo 8 tercios de x al cubo y luego
la anti derivada de este de aquí es 8
quintos de x a la quinta
ocho quintos de quizá la quinta va y
evaluamos de 0 a 1
entonces vamos a pasarnos a la línea de
aquí abajo para evaluar esta integral
nos queda ocho quintos de nada más ocho
quintos verdad menos ocho quintos
y luego tenemos que restar estoy aquí
evaluado en 0 esto de aquí nos va a
quedar muchos ceros pero anoche en
espérame tantito aquí me equivoqué
es ocho tercios verdad ocho tercios por
sí porque estamos evaluando en uno menos
ocho quintos por uno a la quinta que es
ocho quintos y ahora sí vamos a hacer la
resta de fracciones porque nos queda
menos cero y menos cero y entonces ya no
vamos a poner tantos ceros entonces
vamos a restar estas dos fracciones el
denominador común es 15 3 por 5 que es
15 83 lo podemos cambiar multiplicando
el numerador y el denominador por 5
entonces nos queda aquí 40 15 a vos y
aquí hay que multiplicar por 3 arriba y
abajo entonces arriba nos queda
24 - 24 va ya nada más hacemos la resta
40 menos 24 es 16 y abajo nos queda 15
años excelente con esto terminamos de
usar el teorema de greene así pudimos
encontrar que la integral de línea de
este problema de aquí es 16 15 años en
el próximo vídeo veremos un ejemplo más
hasta la próxima